what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down some of the strongest
types of magic also known as magic
attributes in the black clover series I
will be examining their abilities their
strengths their weaknesses and their
potential just to be clear this is not
an exhaustive list and it is not a
countdown this is an analysis of what I
believe to be some of the strongest and
most overpowered magic types in black
clover with that said if there are other
opie magic attributes that you would
like me to cover in a future video just
slap a like on this video and give me
your suggestions down in the comments if
we can hit 3000 likes on this video I
will make a part 2 that features your
suggestions so with that said definitely
leave a like on this video if you want
to see that happen and don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications if you
don't go through the trouble of clicking
the bell and selecting the option that
says all you're gonna miss a lot of our
videos
it's just how YouTube works you can also
hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar finally this video will
contain black / manga spoilers I'm going
to be looking at everything we know so
far about the types of magic that I will
be covering so my intention is not to
spoil you but I will be looking at
information that you might not know yet
with that said please proceed with
caution you have been warned first up
let's talk about light magic easily one
of the most overpowered magic types in
black clover known for its incredible
speed light magic is used by some of the
strongest characters in the series
including the legendary first wizard
King Lumiere and the former leader of
the eye of the Midnight Sun Patri and of
course light magic is also used by the
current king of the clover Kingdom
Augustus Keira clover who is without a
doubt the single strongest character in
the entire series except for a second
anyway
light magic is said to be the single
fastest type of magic out there and as
its name suggests it allows the user to
manipulate light since the speed of
light is like the
fastest thing in the known universe it
makes sense that light magic would be
among the fastest types of magic light
magic is actually a very rare attribute
two of the three known light magic users
in the series Lumiere and Patri use
four-leaf grimoires while Augustus Kiera
clover uses a three leaf grimoire he's
just so strong that he doesn't need that
extra fourth one as with other types of
magic a grimoire is required in order to
bring out the full potential of light
magic the chief strength of like magic
is the user's ability to move and attack
at unbelievable speeds so it is
extremely difficult to defend against
the light magic user the vast majority
of mages in the world of black clover
wouldn't even stand a chance against
light magic so only the most skilled
mages who also happen to possess strong
magic attributes such as dark magic or
time magic are capable of standing
toe-to-toe against a strong light magic
user and speaking of dark magic this
attribute has been referred to as the
polar opposite of light magic we'll talk
about dark magic in a little bit but
before that it is important to point out
that aside from being incredibly fast
and arguably the single fastest type of
magic light magic is also capable of
generating some extremely powerful
spells by the way definitely do not take
a shot every time I say the word magic
in this video you will be screwed the
power of light magic isn't just about
speed the potential destructive
capability of light magic is something
that cannot be ignored
for example Patri can create deadly
blades swords whips and other types of
weapons using his light magic and he can
then launch them at his opponents at
breakneck speed with the light magic
spell called arrows of judgment Patri
has demonstrated the ability to create
countless blades made of light at the
same time blades which he could then
drop on an entire city at once
potentially killing thousands of people
we've also seen Lumiere the first wizard
king using very powerful light magic
spells such as creating giant swords and
arrows of light and using them against
his enemies or simply launching beams of
light right at his opponents using his
light magic Lumiere was able to
decisively defeat left giant demon
transformation although it is fair to
mention the licks consciousness was
actually fighting
against his own demonic body and he
wanted to be defeated by Lumiere on top
of being used for offensive defensive
and movement spells light magic can also
be used for other important functions
such as healing for example poetry is
able to use light healing magic healing
ray of light in order to heal his own
wounds so light magic is clearly
extremely fast and versatile and it has
many different applications it can help
the user move quickly attack quickly
defend quickly and heal themselves
quickly as well light magic spells can
range from short range limited scale
spells such as generating a single small
blade of light to long range spells that
are massive in their scope such as pot
trees arrows of judgement most
impressive of all the light magic spell
called absolute monarch of divine
brilliance allows its user augustus kira
clover to project a huge image of
himself into the air not only does this
spell allow you to look really cool
especially at night but it also serves
as free marketing by allowing you to
turn yourself into a massive shining
billboard think about the free publicity
and massive brand awareness that you
could generate by using absolute monarch
of divine brilliance need to attract
people to your shady car dealership no
problem
need to stand out from the crowd and an
anime convention you got it need to help
your neighbors illuminate the street
during a blackout what better way than
projecting a huge golden version of
yourself into the air
sure like magic has many great uses and
overpowered spells but we cannot and
must not underestimate the power of the
absolute monarch of divine brilliance
next up let's talk about the so called
polar opposite of light magic and that
is dark magic the only known user of
dark magic in black clover is none other
than Captain Yami of the black bull's
dark magic is one of absolute favorite
magic attributes in all of black clover
but to be fair part of the reason why I
love dark magic is the fact that yami
suka hero is one of my favorite
characters in the entire series hasta
Yami and meadow Leona are probably my
top 3 favorite characters and I can't
really make up my mind which one of them
I love the most definitely let me know
down in the comments who your top 3
favorite black clover characters are
anyway dark matter
is a very rare magic attribute which
enables its user to create and control
darkness as usual a grimoire is required
in order to bring out the full potential
of dark magic and Yami possesses a three
leaf grimoire which he uses to great
effect however Yami doesn't just use a
grimoire because dark magic on its own
is actually quite slow and much slower
than say light magic Yami combines dark
magic with a japanese-style katana sword
in order to increase the speed of his
magic
so Yami covers his sword in darkness and
then he uses the sword to swing direct
and manipulate the darkness more quickly
than the magic is capable of moving on
its own
dark magic is capable of wrapping itself
around objects and potential opponents
very effectively and Yami is able to use
this to his advantage in battle
dark magic slow speed makes it
vulnerable to faster types of magic like
light magic but extremely skillful use
of dark magic in combination with other
objects like a katana can make up for
that as is evident from Yami's example
but despite being relatively slow dark
magic does have its advantages for
example dark magic is capable of
absorbing other spells including light
magic spells dark magic is also the only
known magic type that isn't directly
connected to demonic power but still has
an effect on otherworldly demon beings
such as the kotodama demon finally dark
magic is capable of cutting through
spatial magic which was thought to be
impossible we're still not sure why
exactly dark magic has such unique and
rare properties but I hope that we will
learn more about it eventually as the
story goes on dark magic can be used for
a wide variety of cutting and slashing
attacks it can be used for spells such
as black cocoon which allowed the user
to create a protective shell made of
Darkness a shell which they can then use
as a protective barrier and also as a
means of transport dark magic can also
create black holes which attract and
absorb other types of magic and so on
the strongest dark magic move that we've
seen to date is dark cloaked dimension /
Equinox which allow the ami to tap into
all of the mana around him channel it
into a dark cloaked dimension / and then
direct that slash into a long-range
attack that ultimately played an
important role in defeating the
a demon personally I think that light
magic is far more practical and far
easier to use than dark magic and the
speed of light magic should
theoretically give it an advantage over
dark magic however when a dark magic
user is as highly skilled as Yami and is
able to augment his dark magic with
impressive samurais skills the dark
magic user is likely to win in battle
against the normal light magic user
mastering dark magic requires more work
and more skill but an incredibly skilled
user like Yami can make up for dark
magics weaknesses while bringing out the
full potential of its strengths
including dark magics unique abilities
to absorb other types of magic and also
to cut through spatial magic and
otherworldly demon magic and now I want
to talk about another type of magic that
I absolutely love and definitely one of
the strongest types of magic that we
have seen thus far and that is kotodama
magic just like oz does anti magic this
type of magic comes from the alternate
dimension also known as the demon
homeworld and kotodama magic allows its
user to alter physical reality with just
his words the user can summon monsters
sword Spears spikes and all sorts of
other magical and non magical weapons by
just mentioning them verbally on top of
that the user of kotodama magic can use
his words to directly manipulate a wide
variety of objects and living beings at
will Kodama magic is so overpowered that
the vast majority of magic types from
this world have no effect on the
kotodama demon the only exceptions are
Yami's dark magic and asked us anti
magic and we know that hasta Santa magic
is also directly connected to a demon
from the other world even though the
kotodama demon was successfully defeated
by the magic Knights of the clover
Kingdom it is important to remember how
many incredibly strong mages had to work
together as a team in order to defeat
him including the first wizard King and
the resurrected lifts not to mention
hasta yami you know Charlotte knows el
sucre and everyone else left to their
own devices none of these mages could
have taken out the kotodama demon on
their own and that goes double for
anyone whose magic doesn't even have an
effect on him Yami's dark magic and
hasta Santa magic are the only magic
types that could threaten the kotodama
demon but without the support of all of
the
they're magic nights and magic night
captain's it's hard to imagine that
either Yami or hasta could have stood up
to the power of kotodama magic on their
own all in all I absolutely love all
three magic types that I mentioned in
this video including the incredibly fast
light magic the difficult to master but
remarkably powerful dark magic and the
otherworldly kotodama magic if I had to
choose which magic type is the strongest
I would have to go with kotodama just
because I love how totally broken it is
I mean the concept of being able to
create and manipulate anything that you
can imagine and then speak out loud is
so opie and so intriguing but we cannot
underestimate the power of dark magic
either especially when wielded by
someone as exceptionally skilled as Yami
finally light magic has unbelievable
speed and versatility it was used by one
of the strongest characters in the
history of the black clover world the
first wizard King and it is also
undoubtedly one of the strongest magic
types in the story let me know what you
guys think do you agree with me that
light dark and kotodama magic are three
of the strongest magic types in the
entire series and which of them do you
like the most if you could have any of
these three magic types which would you
choose and why finally which other
overpowered magic type from black clover
do you want me to talk about in a future
video
time magic anti magic let me know down
below if you enjoy the black clover
content on this channel you want to see
more please leave a like to let me know
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar please don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you can also hit me
up on Twitter and/or Instagram at anime
uproar I want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime uproar patrons who
support our content and make these
videos possible first up let me thank
our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including in
grata a Lola nod of makoto-kun the world
stealers the school bus and Tyson quit
Ino I also can't forget our awesome pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings ell dress very dolla beat
alpha do
Anatoli Cassatt's ki on
Cruz team Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan
Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy E
vodkas Jean d'Arc and Joe Stanton if you
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our page
and exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see us Binks Cowboys
[Music]